you're not gonna increase your revenue
your traffic your sales unless you take
growth seriously perfection is overrated
nothing's ever perfect you're gonna
continue to have to iterate so forth so
on why would you expect someone to just
come to your website and be like hey buy
something for a thousand dollars okay
here's my credit card
right he's an entrepreneur investor and
analytics expert he's best known as the
co-founder of KISSmetrics
and crazy egg in addition to founding
companies he's well regarded as a writer
and a block
he's neil patel and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success remember
three is my personal favorite and I'm
curious to figure out which one you guys
like the best also as Neil is talking if
he says something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
before we get started I want to tell you
one quote from a guy named Adam Nash and
it's very important in which growth is
important and all good companies take it
seriously
you're not going to increase your
revenue your traffic your sales unless
you take growth seriously for example
you know Facebook you know what their
internal metric when they first started
out was how many more users were they
adding per day and they weren't just
looking at it as a pure number so if
they had a thousand users the first day
and the second day they had another
thousand users and then the third day
they had another new thousand users
that's slowing growth percentage-wise
you're not growing as fast so their goal
was to grow a faster percent than the
previous day right if you take growth
seriously you can actually do quite well
you need to execute and you need to
execute as fast as possible because the
thing at the end today is whether you
feel you have competitors or not sooner
or later you're gonna have someone and
if you can't move fast enough someone's
going to beat you to the punch so make
sure whatever you're doing you get
something out within a month or two if
it takes you longer than that you're
taking way too long
I created this company called surf and
it was in Rockwall Texas right by Dallas
and I had this brilliant idea have any
of you guys heard of the media temple
grid server solution that was my idea a
year or two before I came out and I
spent a million bucks on it trying to
actually do that idea before media
temple this funny thing is that I have a
million bucks so actually had a borrow a
million bucks and I sped it spent it on
business partners who moved really slow
and really weren't the best at what they
did within 12 months we launched nothing
they also had some of the Proms in my
previous slide right like financial
instability they had a family and kids
of I think like six
so even bottom a home in Rockwall Texas
that cost two hundred and something
thousand why did I buy it instead of
renting
I have no clue oh stupid and young but
nonetheless I lost over a million bucks
on that a borrowed money not investor
money but borrowed money that I had to
pay back and it failed miserably because
we never launched anything if you can't
allow something someone like me to
tumbles gonna beat you to the punch
get a ton of customers and make a lot of
money so lessons I learned from that set
deadlines no matter what you have to set
deadlines people have to be held
accountable to him as well right can't
just set deadlines it passes nothing
happens someone better be medium if not
you know something has to change you
also need to make sure they're small if
the deadline if they're like milestones
goals are too big for those deadlines
they're not going to get met so make
them really small and tangible that way
you can see it really well in advance if
they're actually going to be met or not
and last but not least don't worry about
perfection a lot of people like dude I'm
gonna create the most perfect version of
you know whatever it may be that
software has a lot of buzz mine's gonna
be perfect perfection is overrated
nothing's ever perfect you're gonna
continue to have to iterate so forth so
on it's never going to be perfect
there's always going to be issues just
get it out there and start trying to
make money I continually learn from my
mistakes and other people's mistakes see
entrepreneurs think that hey to create
that billion dollar company 100 million
dollar company or even million our
company had to be really smart and sure
brains is part of it luck is a huge
component but what I've learned over the
years is everyone no matter how smart
you are you're gonna fail many times
you're going to make mistakes just look
at Mark Zuckerberg Facebook worked out
his version of snapchat that was a
copycat did not work out right so
there's other areas in which Facebook
failed but Facebook overall as a company
has done great just because you're smart
doesn't mean you're always going to
succeed with everything you try your
touch but every time you do something
you will learn new things you'll make
mistakes and if you learn from these
mistakes and avoid making them over and
over again you'll actually increase your
odds of succeeding as time goes on
and the best way to do this is not just
to learn from your mistakes but it's
also to learn from the mistakes of
others Rockefeller Carnegie all these
people who are entrepreneurs years ago
in the 1800's 1900s they themselves use
business principles and concepts that
are still applicable in today's world
sure we have the internet but the same
strategies and concepts that they use
are still applicable right so learn from
their mistakes learn will work for them
what didn't work for them why and bring
that into what you're doing today so
conversion optimization is like dating
right so if I go up to a random person
let's say the lady looking down on her
lap up anyone unbound sure what's your
name what's your name
Nadia if I say will you marry me right
now chances are you're gonna say all
right if she was single she would still
probably say no why would she say no yes
she is smart
but what's other yeah okay not enough
date about what else if someone comes up
to you in the middle of the street and
just say will you marry me I don't care
if they look they're Victoria's Secret
model right why would you say no or I
don't care if they're Brad Pitt exactly
you don't know um that's right whoever
said that give yourself a pat on the
back that's the way the internet works -
why would you expect someone to just
come to your website and be like hey buy
something for $1,000 okay here's my
credit card
right I wish the world work like that
but it doesn't but once you get to know
people they're much more likely to say
yes right just like you date someone get
to know I move in together you ask them
to marry you
hopefully they say yes if not you kind
of wasted some time but here's what most
funnels look like someone comes to your
website sign up and you generate some
sales right so I decided to do something
I'm like you know what why not flip
around the funnel why not get people to
actually use a product before actually
try to charge them put in a URL first
from there what's your goal start
creating product or
it actually caused a 52.1 1 percent
increase in signups all by switching it
around still ask for their credit card
just about more signups why because
people got to play around with the
product a bit before they actually
bought focus focus focus you heard the
same as Generation Y kids have a didi
right that's what we all say well if you
have a didi you know you got to figure
out how to focus and here's the thing
there isn't enough time in the day to do
multiple things think of it this way I'm
a single guy I'm 27 now and if you think
about definitely 24 hours in a day 7
days a week let's say you sleep I need
my eight hours of sleep I'm cranky it's
like you know you hang out with family
whatever maybe you don't really have
more than 70 to 80 hours to work every
single week
if you barely have money and there's not
enough time in the day to work right to
get everything done that needs to be
done how can you do multiple businesses
and do two businesses at the same time
it's just not gonna work unless you're
Elon Musk and I got to say that guy's a
badass right like when people ask him
what do you do he can say oh one of my
companies competes with Toyota it was
the other one do I compete with NASA
right like he's a badass
I need a CEO of both of them and their
billion-dollar companies unless you're
Elon Musk don't try to two companies out
once right he put in when people
wouldn't give him money and one
interview he's like no one give you
money I just put in a hundred million
bucks of my own money right like the
guy's really a badass and probably none
of us in this room are him so don't try
to do two businesses at once focus idea
number six get personal and I got this
idea from Facebook years ago do you
remember when you're on Facebook like
five years ago and you would see all
these ads your friend has a crush on you
you remember that those guys made a
killing there were stammers but they
made a killing and I'm not saying you
should spam but you can actually learn a
lot from these kind of people don't do
the shady stuff they're doing but take
that ethical tactics that they're doing
and replicate them and throw out the
shady business model
so dating sites make you feel special
very special right they tell you when
you go to these sites OkCupid match.com
uh what else is there a tinder doesn't
do it because Tinder's Mobile Bay
actually tinder kind of does it it's geo
base right they make you feel special so
if I'm logging in from Vancouver and I
go to match I don't know if matches here
it's a IAC company it usually says hey
there's you know five thousand six
hundred and thirty nine singles in
Vancouver what are you waiting for right
I say oh that's a lot of single people
in Vancouver maybe I should sign up so
we tested this out on Tim Sykes comm I'm
determined to create a millionaire
trader in Las Vegas my only question is
will it be you right Tim is down to
create a millionaire trader he's done
this many times we started using geo
based data the sign up rate actually
increased quite a bit we decided to do
the same thing on my site do you want
more traffic
hey I'm Neil Patel I'm determined to
make a business in Las Vegas successful
my only question is will it be you
the best part about this is for all the
people around Las Vegas or cities like
that geo tartines not exact so it may
say Las Vegas even when someone's like
3040 miles away you know how many emails
we were getting per day like hey I
applaud I really want to do I'm not
based in Las Vegas but I'm only 20 miles
away I can drive traffic's not too bad
right
people are really engaged like wow this
is personal it's just a opportunity for
someone who's in Las Vegas heck he
doesn't surface in nor do i we don't
service people in Hamburg Germany but if
you go to the page or show up Hamburg
Germany if you're in Hamburg Germany
right that's what we do then we also
took this data and decided to throw it
throughout all the steps from geo
popping in the name changing it to a
multiple step process instead of single
so that way people actually feeling
special throughout the whole signup
process
you know what happen 68% increase
engagements so conversions jump roughly
30% from signing up but engagement was
more important what I mean by engagement
I'm talking about
LTV of the customer customers were
staying 68 percent longer and I know
that may not sound like a big deal right
but it's really hard to keep customers
if your customer is really staying for a
year and you're getting them to stay for
an extra like 7 months that's huge right
that's 7 months worth of extra money so
personalizing a site making people feel
special like they do on the dating sites
can really help you grow your revenue I
really love what I'm doing not just so
much for people I call find your passion
and go do it a lot of people claim
something is something they really like
but I enjoy marketing so much in
creating companies for marketers that I
work my butt off and it doesn't seem
like work right I can work 70 80 hour
weeks consistently and not have to worry
about it never stresses me out and never
feel like oh I should take a vacation or
any of that I really do enjoy working
what workaholic so loyalty matters
hiring good employees isn't enough you
need how to loyal employees because it
happens that's just not in your control
right I was part of this company called
fruit cast I put in a hundred grand me
my co-founder and this dude came up to
us with idea we said for business we
barely did it in work we just put in
more of the capital it was when
podcasting was hot everyone remember
podcasting that thing that no one
listens to anymore so when podcasting
was hot and you just had the iPod
without the video right we created this
company kind of like Google AdWords but
for podcasts because it's taking off we
could automatically take your podcast
that you were creating and putting ads
for you and do it on demand paper listen
model and it was hot right a lot of
companies were hitting us up at agencies
we even had a lot of buyout offers and
it didn't go through the reason the
buyout offer didn't go through and it
was from a big search giant you can take
a guess there's only three but the
reason it didn't go through because he
was
dude why would I want to work from that
would be stupid I like doing my own
little business and I'm like dude I just
give you a hundred grand for this
business and you're telling me you're
not passionate about it you don't want
to do it full-time or you don't care for
it I'm like what I give you the hundred
grand for it right so I learned that
it's really important to have passionate
people like the other thing to keep in
mind is I've also been through lawsuits
class-action lawsuits when you don't
have loyal people that don't fit in with
your culture they're gonna leave you
during my last class action lawsuit my
last and hopefully only one we actually
had no employees who left us which is
pretty amazing right you're running out
of capital
customers were leaving us and the
class-action lasted a long time like
over a year and no one left us and it's
because they really fit in with culture
we took care of me and my co-founders do
whatever we can for our team members
right because it's like they're family
so it's like when you treat them that
way they're gonna treat you that way and
it's a win-win situation so lessons
learned hire people who fit within your
culture Tony Hsieh does a great job of
this when you're interviewing he'll pay
you to quit right away if you want to
quit and take the money you can take the
money but he knows that you're a bad fit
make sure everyone has similar short
term and long term models people try to
buy you out if everyone on the team
doesn't have that same golden objective
a lot of your team members won't go
which means that your company's not
going to be valued the same you also
need to be transparent I've always been
open with my team and by being
transparent it's helped create a good
culture and a healthy one where they
stick with me and I continually stick
with them you have to keep in mind
humans are inherently lazy when you're
blogging you need to be consistent if
you're gonna write a post right
continually if you're gonna write once a
week you better write once a week I
don't care if it's a holiday I don't
care if you're sick you're gonna do once
a month and stick to once a month
worst case you should stick to once a
month and then if you have more time
ramp it up to twice a month and once a
week etc I got lazy one time with my
current blog quick sprout years ago and
I took a whole month off my traffic was
climbing almost every single month prior
to that
when I took a month off how many months
do you think it took for me to recover
that traffic three I had a blog
consistently every week for three months
just to recuperate my traffic back to
where it was versus it growing on a
consistent basis now sure the blog won't
ever go to zero but it does go down so
by continually adding more information
you're going to find growth when you're
also doing this you need a creative
conversation
Wellum blogging you can use the words
you and I it helps create a conversation
right Chris set illusion so if you read
my content quick spot you'll notice a
lot of use and eyes helps keep people
engaged makes them scroll longer stay on
the page etc comment right in essence
I'm creating a virtual conversation and
I kid you not it works the other thing
is don't act smart when you blog dumb it
down so not only could you create a
conversation by using you and I keep it
simple
don't try to be more sophisticated or
smarter than your readers you need them
as much as they need you you actually
may even need them more right so be
friendly with them once you've got the
conversation piece down you need to
focus on headings right so you see
headings within your blog post you need
to use them three to five times this
will help you break it up it keeps it
simple right how many times have you
guys signed up for a service once twice
three times I bet all of you guys have
signed up for more than 50 services in
your lifetime in which you're putting in
your name and email somewhere would you
agree with that probably even a hundred
right what was if I could tell you that
you would you can sign up for a product
without giving your name email and
password would you be happy assuming it
doesn't break any privacy laws all your
information secure etc would you be
happy yes right well you can so buffer
login with Twitter login with Facebook
logging Lea with LinkedIn or log in with
the email address a lot of people are
doing it I understand there are social
media business but anyone can do this we
do this at KISSmetrics
metric sells b2b solutions for
businesses so you would think oh people
would use our corporate email address
you know Facebook without word
especially Gmail right you guys wouldn't
think Jima would work for a business
that only sells other businesses well we
decided to test it out sign up with your
Google account we didn't even give
another option that stated also sign up
with your email we made you sign up with
your Google account right just that one
little change increase signs by fifty
nine point four percent then we decided
to do something funny I can see the
unbalanced person shaking head you're
going to try this aren't you all right
try this after I even work better so we
decided to do something else we're like
you know what I hate signing up I don't
mind logging into sites but I don't like
signing up so we decided to change a
call-to-action button to say hey log in
with Google right we've got another
twenty two percent increase in signups
just by changing the word from sign up
to log in so if you take both the
conversion rates the fifty nine and the
twenty two it compounds right you're
looking at roughly like a 90 plus
percent increase in conversions that's
not too shabby all by just using Google
and we have customers like Microsoft
Amazon etc they all signed up through
the Google funnel and you would think
people have Microsoft aren't using Gmail
I can prove to you they are right so
someone's telling you oh it's not going
to work it's not worth testing you know
what try it out you can't go wrong
just send 10% of your traffic what's the
worst that's going to happen so try out
these tactics it doesn't matter if your
ecommerce
lead-gen service based business you can
always test out these tactics I've done
on all these types of sites and it works
I guarantee you actually will see more
growth from your business if you don't
you can email me heckle me and I'll
actually give you free advice take care
thanks
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Ernesto Bal
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did Neel say that really
inspired you really motivated you or
what did you learn from him please leave
it in the comments and I'm going to join
in the discussion finally what they give
a quick shout out to Cyrus Webb Cyrus
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book and tweet it out as well I
really really really appreciate it so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
here's a KISSmetrics story four years
ago which is roughly wooden shard maybe
a bit more than that now I think we're
out four and a half we took a million
dollars in seed funding from some angel
investors we created a version with that
it was called version 1.0 we were going
to create a better Google Analytics
right everyone uses Google Analytics
here probably have some issues with
Google and looks right like yeah it
could be better well we were going to
create a better version and we were
going to charge you for it what was the
issue no one wanted it because they
loved how Google Analytics was free but
I built it because I wanted it terrible
idea right spend a year on that version
too and at this point we were running
out of money so we had to raise another
round we raised three million bucks
version two only took six months this
time didn't take a year we created a
Facebook analytics company off of Dave
McClure's our metrics you know like the
pirate a ARR or something like that that
didn't work out as well we found out
these Facebook gaming companies actually
don't make that much money or have a ton
of money to spend on games don't believe
me look at Zynga stock right it's in the
[ __ ] so it really is these games last
for like six months and then they go
down but that's what I was trying to
build a product for learning the hard
way that they have a ton of data which
is costly to compute and they don't want
to spend much money at all version 3
took less than 30 days to launch funny
enough that was the version that we
actually currently have we've iterated
on it but it's the version that people
continually pay for and the business is
thriving right lessons learned from this
create a minimal Viable Product it's
Eric Reese's and you know like preaching
his whole thing and VP lean startup
great book funny enough he's been an
advisor to our company from day one but
it took us like a year and a half to get
there I don't know why but you know we
learned the hard way as you can see I'm
on the business side not the engineering
side and my co-founder is also business
guy so but it's worked out so when you
release a product you do a minimal
Viable Product what that is is you get
something out there as quick as possible
and you get feedback for example when we
want to launch a new feature report we
actually survey people and just get
input and then we'll go create
wireframes and designs that are
clickable we won't even develop it and
be like hey what do you think about this
we'll put fake tit and then people like
oh cool I like this I want to see this I
wish I could do that blah blah blah we
keep on iterating and eventually we're
create a version that actually works and
let people test it out with their data
and iterate more until we get product
market fit which means that people are
saying I'm really satisfied with your
product and I'd be devastated if it no
longer existed which means that they'll
talk about your product a lot the
word-of-mouth marketing will spread
they'll be willing to pay a lot more
turn will decrease stuff like that right
so go for product market fit you can
google it to look at the product market
fit pyramid and how that works and again
don't worry about perfection when you're
doing all this kind of stuff it just
helps you get our products much faster
people will drop off unless you give him
a reason to stick around so one of my
buddies Mike we are talking I'm like
what makes you stick around and we're
drinking beers and he's like those virus
checkers right he runs McAfee and noren
on his computer all the time and it
actually causes him to stick around
because when it tells him there's a
virus he has to stay and find out what
it is so he finishes the whole test why
he gets viruses on his computer that's a
whole different issue
hey but he has a problem so he's always
thinking around for McAfee so I decided
to analyze people's websites and tell
him that there's errors as they progress
there's more and more errors right
assuming we find them instead of showing
them the errors I say put in your
information right I've got more people
to put in information give them a reason
to stick around because there's like
there's errors right 63.5%
increase and responses we are collecting
leads so not only were we getting more
leads but we had a 63 plus percent
increase in people actually following up
because we're giving them a reason to
stick around if you're entrepreneur
you're looking for aggressive growth
there's three things you need to do one
you need to leverage content marketing
give away the best information out there
the information needs to be so good that
your competitors won't dare to copy you
number two you need to create unique
business steals so everyone looks at
marketing as the best way to grow
actually see it as business development
is the best way to grow if you can
strike up interesting deals with other
businesses that already have a user base
you can quickly grow and expand your
user base for the fast for example if I
run a marketing company and I'm trying
to get more business owners and websites
to sign up to my stuff GoDaddy is a
perfect company to partner with because
they already have millions of customers
the third tip I would say is just
working really hard in which people want
to grow but they don't want to put in
the time and energy to grow if you're
not willing to put in the hours and keep
at it relentlessly whether you fail or
you succeed just can't stop no matter
what